auch das ist doch nicht wahr ich habe
auf meine tastatur wirklich alles wieder
trocken und herzlich willkommen hier zu
einem weiteren video aufmachen will
ruhig mal zu mir und simon hab
irgendwann mal gibt abgespielt sagt doch
auch mal du vergeht und deswegen mache
ich das jetzt so was muss ich machen ich
muss wahrscheinlich erneut hieß udo ich
muss einfach immer den nächsten flow
erreichen das erste spiel recht
das ist nicht schwer dieses spiel bisher
ok also bisher geht es eigentlich recht
klar das spiel 6 ich sehe böse kann
diese dinge die mir schaden zufügen
kommen aber das lässt natürlich nicht
beeindrucken und zack hier und hier ab
in den florett ok und ab in den floor
nein button you know you want to proceed
niemals das ist doch bisher ist das weiß
jemand eigene dummheit aber bisher schon
wieder das ist doch jetzt hier auch hier
hin
das ist doch so hier drauf jetzt ich bin
gesprungen so ich bin gesprochen
ich bin schwer gesprungen schauen auf
meine hände schaut auf die die teile
hier sorgt gesprungen jetzt geht es
läuft wenn der zuschauer geht
hallo hier bin ich wieder hallo wollt
ihr mich sehen oder nicht hallo hier bin
ich kommen
ja flotten may be the place socceroos
tag im hier vom management hierhin
hierhin hierüber hier drauf so hierhin
hierhin und jetzt ein langen mega jump
die gefa button hands autoriese halt's
maul ich werde nicht aufgeben
bisher geht es echt klar also dass laser
laser wenn ich das bisher mit an per
mario vergleiche dann ist dieses spiel
echt ein klacks dagegen so hierhin
schnell hier hingekriegt mit der laser
ähnlich sorgt erstmal schön erst mal
hierhin ja ich kann mich ja immer wieder
neues red mit diesem doppelten damit
jumping ist constantini to improve ja eh
schon kommen gleich und wider der laser
hier ich muss sie schnell rüber als ob
ihr zwei töchter sind
das ist doch nicht wahr ich war doch die
rede direkt davor
es kann dort a a das ist nicht wahr doch
jetzt hier kommen schnell hierüber
schnell hier hin
das ist auch wieder mit so geringer
verzögerung immer ich drück springen und
dann springt er ist wieder zehn jahre
später das packt mich wieder richtig ab
obwohl ich den bei google chrome schon
so fucking unfassbar viel speicher
zugewiesen habe mich hier immer töten
kann
war der erst mal hierher hier bin said
oder ok hierhin und jetzt schnell rüber
ja ja ja ok freundin ganz ausgeklügelten
plan der lautet laufen
[Musik]
es kann nicht so schwer sein das ist
nicht schwer ich bilde mir das nur ein
dass es schwer ist uecker und zack
flotte die gott jetzt muss man schon am
anfang so mega schnell reagieren
das ist doch springen doch einfach
vielleicht mal da rein jetzt wieder hier
im safe sauen wir gehen schnell hierüber
soll als ob da jetzt ein dritter laser
ist hier fühle ich mich immer noch so
richtig sicher hier ist echt nahe
nee das ist doch nicht warum jetzt hier
in hierüber durch die laser durch um ein
fucking golf allen plattformen
das ist nicht wahr ich jetzt so knapp
geschafft und dann kommt da diese bühne
fliegen
es ist nicht schwer
ja hui ist gar nicht schwer luca ist es
einfach nur ein gott verdammtes spiel
das ist doch nichts gegen das freecom
and giving up at this point niemals ich
vor gott falling platforms es ist
unfassbar traurig gerade nein das kann
nicht sein das ist nicht wahr
dieses spiel bringt mich an den rand der
verzweiflung
und in der waadt
[Musik]
die fehlt
denn hier in hochburg ach so und jetzt
einfach runter dem alter das ist doch
jetzt nicht wahr als ob mich jetzt hier
schon die ganze zeit lasst mich doch da
packt ihn verdammt noch mal einfach
durch ich tue doch niemand dieses ganze
blut hier
es ist nicht wahr es ist kein blut ich
muss es soll ja ich habe da gar keinen r
für das ist nicht wahr da kommt auch
hierüber auch hierhin ich konnte da wäre
das spiel nicht mehr anrühren
ich glaube sogar das gibt ein gefühl ab
2 aber niemals das ist man hier das ende
für mich kommen hier ein wahrlich noch
eben schnell dann komm lass es sein luca
hier wenn es euch gefallen hat gebert 45
prozent habe ich schon geschockt es so
schwer ist das eigentlich gar nicht wenn
es euch gefallen hat will ich mich meine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr andere will
hier spiele in die kommentare chips